I'm very proud to be an American
designer I think the most important
thing is doing our own thing when you
think of America you always think about
freedom and there's a freedom to kind of
do what you want with your wardrobe that
I think is American I think that
American Styles a little more lifestyle
oriented and more relaxed than most of
the world it's more just like America
itself being free and liberating I think
it's people being able to have like a
true individual style you look at
Italian guys and they're always perfect
everything is so precise then you'll see
an American guy and he can be just as
handsome and just as striking but it's
in a completely different way it's a
little more undone imperfectly perfect
and you know like never looking like
you're thinking about it too much
preppy for me is not costumey it's it's
real clothing that guys are really
wearing and they look really cool
wearing it it doesn't mean it's on the
edge in every period of time but it's
always right people are trying and doing
their own thing the American guys change
so much he's to own maybe a brown pair
of shoes and a black pair of shoes now
the guys like obsessed with shoes like a
woman they're interested I mean there's
a lot more interested in the reading
magazines and they're really plugged in
their online for me it's like a switch
has been flipped and all set American
men are really interested in style I
think fashion and rock and roll had been
tied together since the fifties there's
celebrities that actually you can see
their own personal style than ever lying
on a stylist Kanye West you know he
wears everyone who makes us everything
everybody and you never know exactly it
just looks like him then there's ones
that you can see then style that's why
the whole celebrity culture of dictating
what's going on in fashion is not
reality really because it's somebody
else picking it out for them
you look in the mirror if it's not
working for if you're trying to be
somebody that you're not it's just
didn't it never you never pull it off
and I think just figuring out what your
own style is right and like would you
feel most comfortable in